I want to remind you guys that as we're getting into SEO,
as we're talking about SEO questions, and by the way,
this is the part after you get the deal and I've had this question asked like,
can you not build a website? Can we just have the one pager? Can we have the ads running the
one pager and we charge a thousand and we spend 500 and take the difference? Yes, we can. I've done
it. I did it on accident and I've made money for a whole year, made whatever, $600, $6,000 net,
because it was $1,500, made 500 bucks a month times 12, $6,000 net, didn't even know. Yes,
you can. However, I would highly, highly, highly, highly encourage you that once you get the deal
and you get enough deals that your bills are covered and you are like, okay, now it's time
to go and build these properties that you take the profits and you actually go and build the
properties because this is the part that makes the business model really sexy. The business
model is sexy even if you just do the arbitrage, thousand bucks a month, 500 and ads take the
difference, but it becomes really sexy if it's a thousand bucks a month that you're getting paid
and you can turn the ads to a hundred bucks a month or to 50 bucks a month or completely off
and you can make 90 plus percent profit margin. This is another thing that's so dope about SEO
is it mitigates your risk. If we're only relying on ads and all of our leads are coming from ads
and then something changes with ads, we're screwed. What I recommend is if Google has
a way to get leads, let's try to tap into all. Let's try to get leads from ads. Let's get leads
from GMB and let's get leads from the organic. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
We need to be getting all of this special delivery, thank you, of the monster. I told
my wife to bring this thing up because you just never know when I'm going to need that. Thank you.
Thank you. We want to mitigate our risk. We want to have leads coming in from ads,
we want to have leads coming in from GMB and from organic. For those of you that are freaking out
going, oh my gosh, I haven't got any GMB, blah, blah, blah. Guys, I've gotten tons and tons and
tons of deals where all I had was organic leads coming in. No GMB, no ads, but again, if we can
get leads coming in from all three different areas, it mitigates our risk. Number one is that.
Number two, this is the last thing that I wanted to cover is with SEO. Number one, make sure that
we do build the website because that's what changes it from a great business model to an ultra sexy,
the best business model with the highest profit margins with low risk. We mitigate our risk.
We secure ourselves in those positions and we keep our clients. Make sure we build those websites.